we have this story from axios and
actually we were going to lead with the
Elon Musk stuff promoting one as well
and it's massive 100 million views or
whatever and then I can't remember who I
think was it you or someone mentioned
that this story axio says YouTube
reverses misinformation policy to allow
U.S election denialism and they say the
company's confirmed in a reversal of its
election Integrity Policy YouTube will
leave up content that says fraud errors
or glitches occurred in the 2020
presidential election and other U.S
elections the company confirmed to axios
on Friday the election was stolen from
Richard Nixon in the 60s when you think
Mayor Daley and Hillary Clinton Mayor
Daley no but uh uh we started talking
about this and then as soon as we
brought it up Sheamus started doing
Gollum As Trump saying
precious my precious so uh there you go
I couldn't believe it but uh there's a
very obvious reason why they're doing
this
Donald Trump is likely going to win in
2024. in 2025 he will be inaugurated
they're going to lose their minds the
far left is going to Rampage through DC
and set fires and burn things down like
they always do and then the Democrats
are going to come out and they're going
to be like it was stolen from us Trump's
working for Russia or insert whatever
country he takes it they takes it you
know Hillary Hillary Clinton is going to
be all in scraggly and be like hey
this new change in policy doesn't change
anything for me because I still I get
the feeling that computers were tallying
votes 5149 in private and not telling us
I'm lying but I have no proof I've never
claimed that it is happening I just
sense the burden of proof is on the
person that's tallying the votes in my
opinion Ian's jumping right into it he's
like we can talk about it again yes we
had Steve Bannon and Steve Bannon talked
about it and you know some people are
like aha now that axio now that axios
confirms the policy is gone Tim's gonna
finally admit no dude you guys know like
I have never been afraid I have never
held back I genuinely think they won by
changing the rules by ballot harvesting
by ballot chasing by lack signature
verification you can call it fraud I get
it you can say it was stolen you can say
it was rigged and all that stuff but it
doesn't get to the real cause and here's
the problem I always had with it
right after the election when Trump is
like it was stolen it was rigged there's
videos of people in Georgia being like
I'm not voting why what's the point and
then uh and then you you lose Georgia
the Democrats and give the Democrats the
Senate because people were just like
it's stolen it's impossible and they
give up yeah the narrative is very
harmful to the actual Solutions too I
was very happy to see Turning Point
action partnering with Scott Pressler
now though they pledged five million
dollars for ballot harvesting efforts in
collaborations with Scott Pressler this
man who's done so much he's finally
gonna get paid hopefully and I'll read
we normally we say the super chance this
is a good one Kyle Miller says YouTube
reversing the election rule could be so
that there are videos to demoralize the
right to not vote interesting completely
agreed if we so right now it's already
demoralizing that we know they're doing
vote in the park ballot harvesting that
uh Universal mail-in voting was
unconstitutional in Pennsylvania for a
period and then the Supreme Court of
Pennsylvania ruled that it was allowed
which I still think is ridic ridiculous
because their constitution actually says
you can't you can't do this it changed a
few words and then they made it legal
then they did ballot harvesting
if you if you just say
that it was stolen and you can't win
people give up if you say hey if you do
what they did you'll actually win so
here's what I think
I actually think there's no way they can
win in 2024 as of right now pending any
variable changes I think if the election
would happen today the Republicans would
win however we'll see what happens you
know just wait a few years the left will
clip that one thing and rip out the X
the pat at the other context of me
saying as of right now my point is the
Republicans have heavily learned Ron
DeSantis and Trump have both said
they're going to ballot Harvest Right
you you add on the the economy the war
the war's bad bad for Biden Biden is
screwing things up when Afghanistan
happened the surrender his approval
rating flipped it was all of a sudden
Biden was causing problems they don't
have anyone yeah they don't and if it
and if the best thing RFK Jr who's
actually polling pretty decently but he
is very anti the The Establishment
Democrats I think a lot of Republicans
would would vote for RFK as well but
they're not going to for a very shallow
reason I think he's got a serious
disadvantage because of his voice which
sounds very shallow but I think if he
had the same ideas and he was in a
different body he would be he would
perform much better yeah the voice is a
big part it's like a reverse JFK Nixon
it's a it's a talking job so that's
that's a good point of all the
presidential uh announcements that I've
heard so far from DeSantis and Trump I
mean Trump suppressor was pretty
lackluster too if you listen to rfk's
because I listened to his entire like it
was 75 90 minutes on Twitter spaces and
it was phenomenal it was really really
good so yes I I agree with you that like
there will be superficial analysis that
says uh I can't like what's up with this
dude's voice but if you actually listen
to the content of his words it's
incredible
to be fair even though he does say some
good things like he's still a Democrat
he's still on the left he's not a social
conservative so like as a conservative I
would not vote of course no here's the
thing if our election was like RFK
versus Trump I think our country would
be in a better position right so I think
the Democrats are horrible he's
certainly less horrible than the rest of
them I prefer his positions to theirs so
yeah I think think he would be a step in
the right direction for the Democratic
party but they don't want the right
direction and that's why they're in the
Democratic party I think Trump is is
very much like liberal I don't think
left right I don't know if those terms
really I mean and he just just ran as a
republican because he's like I got a
better chance in there than going with
the DNC deciding who's going to be the
candidate but do you think so like is
the same thing with RFK because I don't
think of him as like I mean he could
easily be a republican I wouldn't know
the difference interesting so I I hear
what you're saying about Trump you're
absolutely correct that Trump is like
not the most conservative or right-wing
politician in America far from it even
though he's been maligned by the media
as just being this far-right fascist
type uh I like him as far as the other
candidates go he was there's a couple
things he's a couple comments he's made
on abortion especially recently that
have been kind of disheartening for me
but look I mean he appointed the judges
that ended up overturning Roe v Wade
like we can we can attribute good amount
of that Victory to Donald Trump so even
though he's not perfect uh I I do still
like him a lot but you're right it's it
is a little bit it's strange to adopt
that vernacular and call Trump like a
right winger or a conservative because
his positions really aren't that
conservative as you know compared to
what we would consider to be
conservative like 10 years ago right
he's like a New York he's a New York
Democrat a lot of ways I think he's
being very strategic on the abortion
issue though because you do have to get
over the affluent Suburban moms and
females especially in swing States like
Pennsylvania I think he's being very
strategic about that President Trump was
one of the most pro-life presidents we
ever had undoubtedly so I think his
rhetoric around it is very deliberate
because it is going to be an obstacle in
those affluent Suburban areas if you're
going hard on abortion and you can't you
can't really be in politics without
playing politics it's possible I still
don't know if it's Justified or I agree
with it but I do agree with you that
that could be his strategy maybe it's an
attempt but maybe it's what he believes
I don't you know seven minutes ago
we were all laughing and pouring wine
and we're talking about abortion yeah
well look no because we're just pointing
out some of the substantive differences
between the parties too yeah yeah but uh
Friday I don't know Tim what do you
think of RFK overall oh I like him um I
would never vote for a Democrat I mean
really without without any major major
reform it's just not not what about
Vivek ramaswamy as a Democrat well no I
just mean in general oh I like him he's
great in the ring uh the problem is
you know in 2018 I'm talking I'm seeing
these Democrats you have people like
Jeff Andrew he switches parties those
are good things and I was thinking to
myself like you could support a Tulsi
gabbard or at the time I liked Andrew
Yang but I think he's just trying too
hard to to to Pony up and pander
and I'm thinking if we get someone like
Tulsi and we can
you know push the Democratic party away
from The neoliberal Establishment stuff
and then what ends up happening when
these Democrats get in we saw this in
2018 when uh so this is before Jeff
Venture but when these Democrats get in
and they're they're all campaigning
saying we're going to be
moderates we're going to fight for
kitchen table issues then they get
elected and they say they drop to their
knees in front of Nancy Pelosi didn't go
I will do whatever you say and then like
impeach Trump and they go yes my Lord
and I'm like what was the point of
voting for these people all they did was
give their vote to Pelosi for stupid
nonsense yeah they didn't fix any of
these problems they know the economy
they win nuts inside Trump is bad so nah
RFK can do whatever he wants I think
he's a good dude whatever
I'm not voting for a Democrat because if
you get him in all he does is empower
the Democratic establishment Joe manchin
for example he needs to be voted out of
West Virginia he should have switched
parties a long time ago and said I'm
getting away from the stuff it's nuts
instead he empowers them and they
complain he doesn't give him enough
although Cinema left the party good for
her Trump we need them all to leave we
need to just do a total turnover and say
guess what if you've been in office
you're not allowed to come back we're
just going to start foreign
it sort of splintered the Republican
party when Trump came in because he
wasn't really a Republican and now we've
got the freedom caucus so RFK could
Splinter the Democratic party I would
say that Trump splintered the Republican
party because the party wasn't
Republican that's also true when he
entered those those were like
neoconservative big state or big
government guys so I'm glad that he that
he messed it up and and to do a little
bit of pushback on the RFK uh talk I
think that there is no living politician
or American for that matter that has
more impetus and imperative to try and
abolish and just shatter the FBI and the
CIA so for for that reason alone as an
anti-war hardcore libertarian I love
that guy and what I have a question do
you not think Trump has as much of a
motivation to try to shut those agencies
down I don't think so no really okay
because because he he hasn't when he had
the opportunity to provide evidence of
what they have done to him he has fallen
short time and time again whereas RFK
when he does interviews and he talks
about how his his father was
assassinated
um it's really powerful Uncle I think
he's both his father and his uncle oh
right right you're right Robert Kennedy
oh you're right Bobby was going after
the mob pretty hard I was thinking JFK
despite yeah no RFK as well dad and his
uncle and and he he actually did an
interview with Mike Tyson where he lays
out I mean this guy is like an
encyclopedia of knowledge and he's got
the entire case he's like I know the
name of the man who's responsible for
assassinating my father no wow I swear
to you oh you guys check it out guys
he's incredible and and he's also
willing to to have really uncomfortable
hard conversations that are totally
anathema within the Democratic party he
would be even if I don't necessarily
think he can win because he is running
on abolishing the FBI he would be such a
huge Quantum Leap in dialogue amongst
the Liberty excuse me amongst the
Democrats in this country so please do
as well as you can RFK well the
Democrats it's so funny because they
detested the FBI until 2016 when they
all began worshiping it and you think
like somebody anti-fbi someone who was
against the Deep State probably could
have had some success within the
Democratic party until more recently
true even if the party establishment
didn't like them the voters would have
been much more open to that person
that's the whole Russian collusion case
exactly and so with RFK versus Trump I
guess I would say just from a strategic
standpoint part of where it's muddy for
me is I think you're right that that
makes it a bit more personal than what
happened to Trump uh then on the other
hand Trump would only have one term and
not be concerned about re-election now I
think you could say RFK having gone
through that and firmly believing that
these agencies are responsible for two
deaths in his family okay maybe he
doesn't care about a second term yeah
that's that's possible no no finish no
no I I just think that spot like again I
still prefer Trump but from a strategic
standpoint I think that's an interesting
argument he said we don't need eight
years we need five months
he's like I am going to fire all of
these people it is going to be if he's
for real then God bless there's a shift
happening on both sides against all of
these three letter agencies including
the CIA the FBI you saw Jack Dorsey
coming out and saying you know Splinter
them into a million pieces dissolve them
all which is incredible and I think
especially Jack Dorsey being removed
from the pit of Twitter and everything
that he had to deal with all of these
requests he had to deal with I think
there's a shift in the way most of the
public is viewing these weaponized
three-letter agencies yeah I mean it's
strange because people have always been
very selective about this you know the
FBI the CIA The Joint Chiefs of Staff
any of these organizations that admit to
things like you know operation
Northwoods or MK Ultra openly that the
public know of people will still turn
around and say okay they used to be like
that but they're not like that anymore
it's ridiculous isn't that incredible
yeah that we know these things happen
and we're still like yeah and it's not
just that it's not just that these
things happen another claiming they
don't happen anymore it's like there's
other very obvious Shenanigans to put a
light term on it happening before our
eyes like for example everything we
learned through the Durham report and
everything anyone who is observant knew
before the Durham report came out about
the obvious political bias in total
incompetence at best that occurred and
we're supposed to give them the benefit
of the doubt and say this wasn't an
attempt at a coup they were trying their
best but they just happened to have some
bad eggs who are politically motivated
but weren't even in and of themselves
trying to subvert the Democratic process
why would you give them that benefit of
the doubt given the history of these
three letter agencies
slogan no more Shenanigans
Joe Biden was no Malarkey right I love
that Meme where it's like yes we know
the CIA did bad things in the 50s the
60s the 70s the 80s the 90s the 2000s
the 2010s and there's been no meaningful
reform or change or accountability but
now everything's good exactly this time
is different what drives me crazy though
is that this should be a bipartisan
issue like you have Martin Luther King
Jr for God's sakes and the Democrats are
now running cover for the FBI like what
are you guys doing
this say we don't like the Democrats but
we March behind them right well exactly
because they know that the Democratic
party is very useful to them right now
so it doesn't matter what the facts say
what matters is what's politically
expedient in the moment so they'll
always simp for the establishment but
I'll say this they say yeah you know you
you say that you're not conservative or
you're voting for Trump and I'm like
Trump is an Insurgent like Bernie was an
insurgent and Trump is trying to do away
with these institutions with the
intelligence agencies the bureaucracy
the Deep State not perfectly he did he
didn't do that great in his first term
probably because he thought I'll get a
second term and then I'll really kick
butt I also think now he wants revenge
but there's a big difference between
Trump and the Democratic party which is
the machine establishment the
three-letter agencies and the neocons
who rushed over there because of Trump's
emergence in the Republican Party sure
I'll also throw this out there I just I
wonder how much of an Insurgent Bernie
Sanders ever really is or was because
he's caved into the Democratic
establishment every single time I
remember you know my brother was looking
at Bernie Sanders he was a little
interested in his policies back in 2015
2016. and I remember saying I have a bad
feeling about a man I don't like his
politics but as far as dissidents go I
think he's going to cave and then boom
he ends up endorsing Hillary as soon as
you get the nomination it's like you're
claiming this system is corrupt and
Hillary's part of one of the most
horrific machines that's ever existed in
political history and she takes
advantage of the poor and she starts
where does all these evil things and
you're gonna endorse her really it was
what happened was Bernie he was sitting
down with his his mentor Hillary Clinton
and she said there are ways to retain
your third house there are ways to do it
that the the the actual leftists would
not tell you and then when it came down
to it and the the left was like he must
Hillary Clinton Must Be Stopped she's
evil Bernie goes no I need her and then
you know Hillary shot Force lightning at
the the true leftist leaders and then
Bernie fell to his knees and said and
said I will do whatever you say Hillary
don't take my house please leave me
alone so with Hillary and this is always
what's so hilarious about the
Apologetics they'll engage in for people
like this Bernie Sanders has three homes
and they have all sorts of excuses for
it okay if a retired couple who saved
their entire lives to get two extra
homes rent those homes out for their
rental income so they have three houses
rent two of them out so people can use
them productively and occupy them and
support them in their retirement that's
evil they're scumbag landlords if Bernie
Sanders has three houses and just keeps
two of them empty it's okay he's a great
guy right despite the homeless crisis
all over the place his two empty homes
are totally fine because if you want to
make a million bucks we should write a
best-selling best-selling book yeah just
write a best-selling book well hold on
what about the people who uh worked for
the logging company that took those
trees down what about the people who who
turned that wood into paper what about
the people who printed it shouldn't they
all get a proportional cut of the
profits of that book isn't profit theft
can we just Bernie get all the money he
just he just wrote the ideas he didn't
print the thing he didn't put it in the
stores and he probably didn't write a
lot of the ideas someone else did a lot
of the work but I just love it once he
made a million dollars he stopped saying
the millionaires yeah he'd say the
Millionaires and the billionaires in
this country yes then when you look at
you can see that the moment he became
honest I think it was his financial
disclosure for for congress for the
Senate he makes a million bucks then he
starts saying the billionaires in this
country dude that was more Trump than
this this greedy man couldn't just give
away enough of his net worth to have 999
000 worth of either dollars or net worth
equivalent like he had to hold on to
whatever he has above a million dollars
right and still call himself a socialist
he's like oh just stop saying well you
know yeah but like you could have had
900 000 it's still a good net worth dude
you can tell the crowd there's a
difference between someone with a
million bucks and someone with 999
million bucks you know what I mean like
he just stopped saying it it's like okay
yeah I think it was
either way either he loved Hillary or he
hated Trump but I think it was his he
was afraid of Donald Trump so much that
he was willing to bend the knee
I don't think so I think he was scared
of Hillary Clinton I think he's closer
politically than Trump than he is to
Hillary yes for sure they were they were
but he was saying stuff like Trump is an
existential threat to the world and I
need to make sure
exactly and if you'll do whatever the
the political establishment tells you
you're not very close to Trump well
you're certainly not a revolutionary at
that point
it's true yeah it was brutal that bird
landed on his Podium like that's not an
accident while he was giving that speech
do you remember that I do he was talking
from the heart like he was and then the
bird landed on it he was like it was
like a Gandhi moment for sure clearly it
wasn't but it was like his heart was in
the right place but his brain wasn't and
then you had Mike Pence no fly land on
his face
it wasn't his heart or his brain it was
his balls his gut his guts were on the
right spot and he went I'm so scared of
the democratic establishment is in the
right place or not right
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time